[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 65
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
It feels like we did an
episode just yesterday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is crazy.
It's been so long without
recording an episode.
And we are, today, at Moscone
West here in San Francisco
for Google Cloud Next '17.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's been pretty crazy.
It is a huge, huge, huge event.
And we've had some
fantastic people
coming by at the
booth to come do
some short interviews with us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
been an amazing day.
There is so many people that
we interviewed, all of them
amazing.
There's so many of
them that we will not
be able to show
all of the people
that we talked to, which is OK.
There's also a bunch of
things that we'll not
be able to discuss.
But you should definitely
check out the news
because there's so many
cool announcements.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, you
should totally tune in.
The keynote should be
available for watching.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
keynote's already online.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
So go check it out.
There's all the announcements.
MARK MANDEL: Plenty of press.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's been
much, much, much, much stuff.
So yeah, go check those out.
And instead what we're going
to try to give to you today
is an inside view of what's
going on here at Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
speaking of keynote,
the first person
we interview today,
Sara Robinson, developer
advocate, heart of our team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
amazing Sara Robinson.
MARK MANDEL: The amazing Sara
Robinson did an amazing demo.
And so why don't we
go and chat to her
and talk to her about
all the things she was
involved with in the keynote?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Fresh off the
stage from the keynote,
I'm just delighted to be
joined by Sara Robinson,
a member of our DA team.
Did an amazing job at
the keynote this morning.
How are you doing today?
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
It was fun.
A little scary, but super fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Went out really well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So if anyone,
for whatever reason,
doesn't know who you
are, can you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer
advocate on the cloud
team with Mark and Francesc.
So as DAs, we get to build
demos, give talks about them,
write blog posts.
And I'm focused on big
data and machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And can you tell us a little bit
about the demo you gave today?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
So the demo was of a
new API that we launched
at the keynote this morning
called the Video Intelligence
API, which lets you basically
get granular data on what's
in your video.
So you send in a
video and it gives you
back high level
data, some labels
on what's this video about.
And then it also returns labels
for each scene in the video.
It will tell you different
entities that it finds.
So it could say, oh,
there's a dog in the scene
from second one to three.
And it gives you that data
throughout your entire video.
MARK MANDEL: So is this kind
of similar to Vision API,
but for basically video?
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
Yeah, so if you're familiar
with the Vision API which
gives the metadata
on images, this
does that for video,
which makes it
easy to search a large
library of video content
pretty easily to find the exact
scenes you're looking for.
MARK MANDEL: So what was the
actual demo you did on stage?
SARA ROBINSON: So
that demo was an app
that I built with
another developer.
And it's actually a Node.js app
that runs on Google App Engine.
And it uses cloud
functions under the hood,
lots of Google Cloud
technology coming into play.
So the way it works is there
was a Google Cloud Storage
bucket with all the videos.
When you add a video
to that bucket,
there's a cloud
function listening
that sends a video
to the Video API
and then writes the
JSON response back
to a separate Cloud
Storage bucket.
So the app is not calling
the Video API directly.
It just calls the front end that
retrieves the video metadata
from the Cloud Storage
bucket and then
the associated annotations
and displays them.
And it makes it super
easy to implement search
because you have all that
annotation data in your JSON
response.
So you can search
your video library
and find the exact clips
you're looking for.
It was definitely a
fun demo to built.
MARK MANDEL: It looked
really, really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
was actually thinking--
I don't know if you know the
literal video version, what
a literal video version is.
It's like basically
you show video clips,
but instead of
having the song, you
have a sung description of what
the video is showing instead
of what the music is normally.
SARA ROBINSON: Oh, that's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I was thinking
is that would be an amazing
demo for this feature.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, something
we thought about doing
but thought it might be too
much for the keynote was
as the video plays, kind of
have the labels bubble up
that are showing at
that point in time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
would be so cool.
SARA ROBINSON: Might
add that later.
We'll definitely continue
to use this demo,
tweak it, take it on the road.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So other than your amazing
demo and the keynote
in general, what are you
excited about for the rest
of the conference?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
so I'm actually
doing a session tomorrow
which will cover
the Video API in more detail.
But it's focused on all
the machine learning APIs
that we have.
So there will be five in total--
Video, Vision, Speech, Natural
Language, and Translation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that
is tomorrow at 11:20?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, 11:20.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 11:20, great.
SARA ROBINSON: Other
sessions-- there's lots
of great sessions on big data.
I know Felipe is doing one on
public data sets and BigQuery,
some other machine learning
ones, some deep dives
into Cloud ML Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And also
Mark's session, right?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
Mark's session.
MARK MANDEL: You don't even
know my session is, do you?
SARA ROBINSON: I know
it's with a customer.
MARK MANDEL: There
we go, a little bit.
That's fine.
SARA ROBINSON: When's
your session Mark?
MARK MANDEL: It's tomorrow,
tomorrow afternoon at 4:00.
SARA ROBINSON: OK, great.
What's it on?
MARK MANDEL: I'm talking
about building large scale
persistent worlds with one
our partners, Improbable.
SARA ROBINSON: Wow.
OK, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds really fun.
And I'm actually going to
be there to watch the demo
because I think it's
going to be pretty cool.
SARA ROBINSON: That's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, Sara, thank
you so much for taking the
time in such a busy day for you
to talk about all the cool
things that you've seen today.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So
thanks again to Sara
for taking some time today
and coming to chat with us.
Her demo, the keynote, the whole
thing about everything she did
was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That was
an amazing, amazing demo.
I mean the product itself--
MARK MANDEL: Is cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --is
an amazing thing.
But the demo was so well done.
So congratulations
Sara, you rock.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And speaking of amazing
things and amazing people,
we also had the
absolute pleasure
of having the director
of engineering at YouTube
come and visit us as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
Sowmya Subramanian
decided to join us after
our panel she was doing.
And she's here to talk to us
about the content of the panel,
but also a little bit
about what is it to be
engineering director at Google.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, she did a
panel about diversity in tech
and how to succeed
with diversity in tech
and why it's actually
so important.
Apparently it was
amazing as well.
You should definitely check
out the recording for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So why don't
we go talk to Sowmya?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
And we're very happy now to
welcome Sowmya Subramanian,
engineer at Google, to the
podcast, "Google Cloud Platform
Podcast."
How are you doing Sowmya?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
I'm doing good.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
very happy to have you.
You just finished a
pretty cool session.
But before we talk about
that session you were on,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about what
you do at Google?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Sure.
I'm a director of
engineering at Google,
and I lead the engineering
efforts for YouTube Music.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty amazing,
but that's not a small
project, obviously.
Like that's--
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
No, it's not small.
MARK MANDEL: --quite
encompassing.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Could you tell us a little
bit above what does it entail
to be director of engineering?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
So at YouTube,
being a director--
I mean at Google, when you're
leading up an engineering
team, that entails a
lot of different things,
starting from figuring out
what is the team doing, what's
the mission of your team,
to really figuring out
your kind of architecture and
design, technical architecture
and design as well as
what your org design looks
like, like making sure you have
the right people on the team
and your scaling, your
resources, your people,
your technology
in the right way.
And really it's pretty
cross-functional.
You're working very closely
with your product management
team and your UX and
the business partners.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Now I know you were
part of a session today
or leading a session today.
What were you doing here?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Yeah, the reason
I'm here at the conference
is I was on a panel.
I was a panelist at a session
around diversity and impact
of diversity to companies.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
And even more than that, we
had one of your colleagues
a minute ago, and
she was telling us
about how it was basically
a how to guide women
to increase their success.
What was the whole
idea behind the panel?
What was the main message?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Yeah, I think
the main message
of the panel was
about how having more diverse
and inclusive thinking,
diverse and inclusive
teams, really affects
the bottom line for
companies, and how
you can go about looking at both
your business models as well
as the people that you
work with in ways where
you're shifting
the thinking to be
more inclusive to drive change.
MARK MANDEL: Were there any
really good techniques or sort
of ideas or behavioral
practices for getting
more diverse teams that sort
of came up in the panel?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Yeah, I think
one that was kind of
interesting that was called out
is whether you're a
startup or a big company,
there are challenges
to making that shift
happen of different kinds.
And the only way you start
addressing that problem
about having a more
diverse team is not just
to believe that a diverse
team is impactful,
but to actually see that
happen and make that change.
So I think that's
one big thing which
is it's not just a number you're
trying to fill out or make up,
but it really does drive
change and impact on growth.
That was one big kind of theme.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
very interesting.
So how many people
were at the panel?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
On the panel?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, on panel today.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: There
were I think six of us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Six of you, nice.
And all of this was recorded.
So the name of the panel--
do you remember the
actual name of the panel?
MARK MANDEL: It's
OK, we'll find it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll find it.
We'll put a link
on the show notes.
I think it's a very
interesting topic.
And it is recorded, so it
will be posted on YouTube--
which you manage--
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--sometime soon.
Is there anything
else that you'd
like to mention,
something you've seen here
in the conference that got
you excited or got you happy
or something like that?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Yeah, I mean, I
was amazed at how many people
are here at this conference.
I think this was the first
time for Google Cloud
to host a conference
of this kind.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Of this size.
MARK MANDEL: Size, yeah.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
And it's pretty amazing
to see the number
of attendees here.
It's really, really exciting.
I mean we use the cloud
and the infrastructure
because all of our
stuff is built on Google
[INAUDIBLE] infrastructure.
But seeing this
be made available
for other companies and
other businesses to build on,
it's really amazing.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, well thank
you so much for
taking some time out
of your busy schedule to come
and join us here at our booth.
And if you're going
to hang around,
I hope you have a great Next.
And thank you again.
Thank you so much.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we go
from an amazing woman in tech
to another amazing woman in
tech, this time not at Google.
She's an SRE manager, so
site reliability engineering
manager, at Dropbox.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
honestly, I actually really
love when we talk about site
reliability engineering.
It's a fascinating topic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is very cool.
And especially she has
really interesting views
because she's an SRE manager
at Dropbox where they
use the same name as Google.
So they're pretty similar but
at the same time, not exactly
the same.
So she's coming to
talk a little bit
about what are all the sessions
that she saw that were cool
and what she's excited
about talking about cloud
and all the sessions
that are coming.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well let's go talk to her.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we are now joined
by Tommy Butow, an amazing human
being that works for Dropbox.
How are you doing?
TAMMY BUTOW: Great, thanks.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, I'm excited to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
We're very excited to have you.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
about what you do at Dropbox?
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, I'm a site
reliability engineering manager
at Dropbox where I lead
the databases team and also
our Magic Pocket team,
which is our block storage.
Yeah, so very busy.
I do two on-call shifts.
But we're pretty good at Dropbox
at doing a lot of automation
making sure that everything is
up and running all the time.
Yeah, really a great
team of engineers.
But you know, it's
challenging to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So it sounds like you know
very well about SRE and stuff
like that.
You actually use the same
name, which is interesting.
Why don't you tell
us a little but
about the kind of
things, kind of sessions
that you're interested
about here at Cloud Next?
Like for an SRE, what
gets you excited here?
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, so There's
some really good sessions
this morning about
the history of SRE.
So SRE started at
Google with Ben Treynor,
He was upstairs doing a
talk, which was really cool.
It's always good
to hear him speak.
He's amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
he's pretty good.
TAMMY BUTOW: And the reason
that SRE was created at Dropbox
was because Andrew
Fong came from Google.
He was at YouTube originally.
And he has been at Dropbox
now for over four years.
But yeah, he took a lot of the
ideas from when he was there.
And yeah, like next,
what I'm really
excited to see this afternoon
is to learn more about
how Google SRE and also
the CRE, the customer
reliability
engineers, are helping
people use Google Cloud.
It's pretty exciting to
me because it is hard.
Like even this morning I
was actually experiencing
a website, it was very slow.
I tweeted the campaigns
and said like, your website
is very slow.
And then they wrote back
and said, do you want a job?
I was like no,
like I have a job.
I understand that
it's very hard to do.
It is really tough to make
your website work well and work
all the time.
So yeah, I'm excited about
where the industry is heading
and that there's
more ways for people
to be supported
when they're trying
to build their own company.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I think
that CRE is exactly about that.
Like growing an SRE team, it's
not easy, as I'm sure you know.
And so having the possibility
of basically getting
like SRE as a service kind
of, that is pretty cool.
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, I
think that makes sense.
MARK MANDEL: We've had
one of my teammates, Paul,
who did a rotation with
the internal SRE team
on the podcast.
And he talked a lot especially
around like SLOs and SLAs,
like basically how up
does your thing have
to be in terms of how much
change you want to do?
Can you talk about that as
well and how that sort of
worked in your org?
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, it's
really well done at Dropbox.
I mean, we got a lot of ideas.
You can also read the
SRE book from Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yeah, and it's free now.
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah,
that book is awesome,
and there's a lot
of tips in there.
And it's similar to
what we do at Dropbox.
But one of the things that
I really love when I first
started at Dropbox--
I've been there for
a year and a half--
is we actually send daily
SLA email reports, which
is actually super handy.
Like it sounds so
simple, but if you just
get that in your inbox every day
and you can see the history--
today, yesterday, like last
week, the last four weeks--
to actually keep track of your
SLAs and where you're hitting,
and then it changes
color based on if maybe
it could get bad or
something like that
so then we can be
more proactive.
That's quite handy.
And then we also set up
alerts to alert on SLA.
I think that's actually
super important.
A lot of people that do that,
they don't actually track where
am I at for my SLA.
Like warning, you're
getting close.
You better actually
do something.
I think that's very good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Have you read the SRE book then?
TAMMY BUTOW: Yes, It's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
is there anything
that it is substantially
different from SRE
at Google and SRE at Dropbox?
TAMMY BUTOW: One of
the big differences
is just the number of people.
There's like so
many SREs at Google.
Our team's quite small.
We only have under
40 SREs at Dropbox.
So we're pretty little.
And also we're not
distributed around the world.
We're more in San
Francisco and Dublin.
So yeah, we're been doing a lot.
We have 600 million
customers at Dropbox,
so there's a lot of
people to support.
We have 500 petabytes of
data, more now maybe perhaps.
So pretty exciting what
we do, but we yeah,
we do have very small teams.
But we take a lot of
inspiration from what's
happening at Google
around automation.
So we do a lot of self-healing.
If something breaks, we don't
have to manually do something.
It automatically heals itself.
And so for us, it's more about
looking after the automation
and continuing to
build new features
and making it even
better over time.
So yeah, we just
don't want to be
doing like manual
work, which you can
have human error there anyways.
It's not a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: So just
out of curiosity, you've
obviously get a lot of
experience with this.
If someone's at a company
and they're thinking,
we should really
start an SRE team,
is the Google book the
best place to start?
Is it somewhere else?
What's the best
resources to get started?
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, I
really like the book.
I think it's very good.
You could also look
up some of the videos
that Ben's done in the past.
Those are really great.
And I've also done a video
too that you can watch.
I spoke at LinuxCon
in Australia,
and I did a talk on site
reliability engineering
at Dropbox.
And it goes through what
we actually do there.
And yeah, quite a few
people have watched that
and learned a lot from it.
And I think for us, we're
always just trying to improve.
We're always getting better.
Things change so fast.
There's new hardware
all the time.
You're building new services.
You're deprecating services.
You're always trying
to move forward.
So I think look for the
newest, most relevant content
that comes out, and look
for some of the wise talks
from the past that
were just really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So thank you so much for taking
the time out of your, I'm sure,
super busy schedule at Next.
And have a great
continuation at Next.
And see you at GopherCon for
your amazing opening keynote.
TAMMY BUTOW: Yeah, I can't wait.
I'm so excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Congratulations on that one.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, fantastic.
Thank you very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
TAMMY BUTOW: Thanks
for having me.
Bye.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm very happy
that we have another Australian
coming to grace our podcast.
There can never, ever
be enough Australians.
She was fantastic.
She was absolutely fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, I
don't know about Australia,
but definitely Tammy
was an amazing person
to have on the podcast.
So thanks again Tammy for coming
and sharing your knowledge.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
For the final interview
though, we have Claire Bayley.
This is really cool because
it talks about our codelabs.
It really kind of
also explores like,
not only can you see
all the videos at home,
but there's also
take-home activities
you can do at home as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think that one
of the favorite things for
attendees here at Cloud Next
is the fact that you
can learn so much.
You have all the
people surrounding you.
You have the meet the experts.
You have all the talks.
But you also have the codelabs.
Important thing-- you can
also do those at home.
So Claire is here to tell
us everything about that.
MARK MANDEL: Hot off
the conference floor,
we have Clara Bayley,
the Global Codelabs
Lead who is running codelabs
right now at Cloud Next.
Well actually not right now.
Right now she's with us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Right, she's with us.
MARK MANDEL: But generally yes.
Claire, how are you doing?
CLAIRE BAYLEY: I'm great.
Codelabs kicked off about
an hour and a half ago.
Tables are pretty full.
Other than being dragged
away to do this podcast,
I'm having a good time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well you're welcome.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what does it entail to
be the global codelabs lead?
CLAIRE BAYLEY:
Pretty much anything
that touches codelabs comes
through me at some point.
A lot of it is stuff
like this where
there's on the ground events--
Next, I/O. We have a lot of
smaller developer summits as
well.
And codelabs are hands on
technical training exercises.
The way we run them
are they're self-paced
and you just kind of show up.
And we've got a computer.
You can bring your own.
And we've got step by
step instructions and kind
of anything you
might want to learn.
And you can run through it
and learn something new.
And we're there to help you.
MARK MANDEL: So is this
something just at Cloud Next,
or can they do it on
their own elsewhere?
How's that work?
CLAIRE BAYLEY: They can
definitely do it on their own
elsewhere.
We have computers provided at
Cloud Next to do them here.
We have Googlers on hand to
answer questions and get stuck.
But they are also online.
So the codelabs from Nest can
be found at google.qwiklabs.com.
That qwiklabs with a W,
Q-W-I-K-L-A-B-S dot com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We'll have a link
on the show notes as usual.
CLAIRE BAYLEY: Excellent.
Yeah, google.qwiklabs.com
for all the codelabs
that are at this conference.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
Could you tell us a bit more
about what should people expect
to learn from those codelabs?
Is it all about specific topics?
What is your favorite one?
CLAIRE BAYLEY: I'm a
fan of machine learning.
So some of those and
the big data ones
are probably my favorites.
They really run
the range though.
Like there are some
very beginner ones.
There's one that's just how
to set up a virtual machine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
CLAIRE BAYLEY: Which like, some
pretty basic level entry level
for cloud, all the way
through to machine learning
and complicated
language specific,
platform specific running
this language on this platform
and deploying it to
this type of server.
They get pretty
complex to give you
an idea of how to
do cloud operations.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very awesome.
MARK MANDEL: So a
lot of our listeners
obviously, I'm guessing, aren't
going to be here unfortunately,
which is a shame.
So if they're
doing this at home,
do they need to set
up a free trial?
How does that kind
of thing work, just
to set expectations really?
CLAIRE BAYLEY: They don't.
As of this conference,
this is the first time
we've used this new
infrastructure, this Qwiklabs
infrastructure.
It's a company we acquired
a couple months ago.
With the Qwiklabs
setup, you don't
have to enter your own account
or your own credit card
at any point.
They generate accounts for
you that last for between half
an hour and an hour
and a half, depending
on how hard the codelab is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
CLAIRE BAYLEY:
Yeah, and then you
just run through it with that.
So it really is a simple easy
trial with zero commitment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So for the people that
are actually here,
are we going to have
the codelabs all day?
Is it 24 hour service?
How does that work?
CLAIRE BAYLEY: Luckily for me
they're not going 24 hours.
They are going from just
after the keynote every day
to basically when
the sessions end.
So all three days there
will be codelabs ready
for you to stop by and try out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's really,
really cool, or awesome.
So if you're here
or you're elsewhere
and you're really
keen to basically get
your hands on with Google
Cloud, check out the URL
or come to the
codelabs at the event.
Awesome.
Well Claire, thank
you so much for taking
time out of your very busy
schedule to come talk with us.
We really appreciate it.
CLAIRE BAYLEY: Thank
you for having me.
It's been fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That was
an amazing conversation.
And I'm actually very excited
about being able myself
to go through those codelabs.
CLAIRE BAYLEY: Yeah,
I want to do them too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
because they're really cool,
and we do not really have
the time here at Cloud Next
because, you know, we're
busy interviewing people.
MARK MANDEL: But no, we
should make a mention too,
if you want to learn more
and you're not here at Next,
you can do the
codelabs yourself.
But there are also extended
events all around the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
think there are like 350.
MARK MANDEL: 350, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there's--
I don't know if there's one
per country or more than that.
I know that there's
many countries where
there's plenty of them.
There was, I think, 80 of
them in the United States.
So even if you were not able to
travel physically here, thanks
to the podcast, I
hope you're having
a little bit of an inside view.
And you can also do
all the codelabs.
You can go watch the keynotes
at the extend events.
And the extended events
are not necessarily
at the same date, which means
that you should definitely
check it out because
maybe it's next week
or in a couple of
weeks, and you still
have the chance to join them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
just go check out.
It says extended on
the Cloud Next URL.
You can go there,
type in your city,
see what events are
happening in your hometown.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is great.
Well, I think that this
is enough for today.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This
is a great, great day,
lots of really cool things.
But there's so much
more coming tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Well, we'll see
you all tomorrow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
[MUSIC PLAYING]